O gobierno alternativo de ovenegan
trata sé de 1 fórmula que está inspirada en
los gabinetes,
en la sombra la tradición parlamentaria inglesa.
O primero es hacer 1 riguroso labor
de control, o gobierno de Asunta.
Cada consejería será 1 exhaustivo seguimiento,
1 marcase estricta por parte de hace 2
responsables de área de este gobierno alternativo,
o segundo objetivo
es explicar las propuestas que adoptaría
1 gobierno dovenegá para resolveros problemas,
2 galegos e das galegas.
Ante cada crítica,
aportaremos 1 solución
eh. Como tercer objetivo,
promover grandes
acordos de país en cuestiones estratégicas
eh, contribuir a darle peso político a galiza, no estado
riguroso labor de control,
proponer alternativas para Dar solución os problemas
D.O. país en mantenida,
para colaborar a favor de galiza.
Esta e a folla de ruta.
Cuaquimos traballar
desde o grupo parlamentario de ovenega,
somos plenamente conscientes
D.O. papel eh, de la responsabilidad
de que nos dieron asurnas,
y desde esa responsabilidad
de da fuerza líder, da posición,
ímos trabajar desde o primero minuto, para Dar ya galiza
1 alternativa, de presente, de futuro,
desde a convicción
de que este 1 Gran país que cañará
con confianza en sí mismo,
en a sus propias fuerzas